I know you did some modeling early on  when you were Victoria's Secret's model  I was for a little bit yeah did you I  believe someone is told me we have a  photograph here oh good lord  [Applause]  absolutely gorgeous did you find that to  be was modeling a natural fit for you or  is it strange well I mean something like  that was so weird for me because it's  like you know the Brazilian bombshells  and like I don't know I'm just not like  that and I mean I I was the whitest girl  on the stage and I'd gone and I'd gotten  a spray tan and I went to them and I'm  like and they were like can you go get  another one I love that and then I came  back with my my second spray tan and I  was still the widest girl on the stage  but you know it was it was fun for for a  while definitely I think I got to travel  the world and I got to experience life  in a way that most people don't get a  chance to  you